well many people walked away with a job
after the mega job fair at the
convention center that happened earlier
on today
yeah this comes as the clock is ticking
on federal unemployment benefits those
are going to expire here in a couple of
months
victoria saha takes a closer look at
what this job fair meant
for people who were out of work the
packed las vegas convention center is a
clear sign that thousands of those who
are still unemployed
are hoping to walk out today with a job
offer and get back
into the workforce kelly andrews is just
one of the thousands that walked into
the job fair not knowing what to expect
but hoped for the best i just got hired
she says she applied to many jobs in the
last several months but
hardly received a follow-up it felt like
on deaf ears until today
and i feel like when you apply online
you're kind of anonymous brandon smith
also shares the same frustration
sometimes i get a call back saying the
position has been filled
sometimes it's usually ghosted i'll say
it's usually ghosted
he didn't get an offer friday but is
expecting a call back
friday's job fair had up to 5 000 job
seekers and roughly 14 thousand
available jobs
with federal unemployment benefits
ending in september
county leaders are glad to see the huge
turnout a lot of people
are still a little bit leery about
getting out in the world so the fact
that
this many people came out is a very
positive sign employers are ready to
hire
at mgm the first hour they gave out 100
job offers
the lines are flooding and we're so
happy to see it
but people are ready to come back to
work and we're ready to put them to work
jobs range from entry level all the way
to corporate level those who didn't land
a job from today's job fair say they
will remain hopeful
and they are glad that they were able to
make that face-to-face connection
reporting from the las vegas convention
center victoria saha 8 news now